-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're getting to the news.
WNBA star Brittney Griner was
released today
from a Russian prison
in exchange for
an international arm dealer.
It's the first time
the U.S. has traded
an alleged weed smoker
for an international criminal
since 2016.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden tweeted this
morning
about the release of WNBA
star Brittney Griner
from a Russian prison
and said, "She is safe,
she is on a plane,
she is on her way home
and I'd say she's happy,
but she's still a 6'9" person
on a plane."
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump's legal
team reportedly found at least
two items marked classified
while searching through
one of his
Florida storage units,
and that's not all they found.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm having trouble
with my rent."
That's right.
Trump's legal team
reportedly found at least
two items marked classified
in one of his storage units
in West Palm Beach.
You needed a storage unit?
How many documents
did you steal?
You live in a hotel.
[ Laughter ]
For the first time in four
decades,
journalists and staffers at
'The New York Times" last night
began a 24-hour strike
to protest
for better salaries
and benefits,
so for today only
there were two reasons
why posting your Wordle score
makes you a jerk.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
it takes
the average American worker
one year and seven months
to feel like they're thriving
in a new job.
Here's the study.
[ Laughter ]
Oprah recently released
the annual list
of her favorite things.
Coming in at number one,
creating a monster!
[ Laughter, groaning ]
[ Laughter ]
Firefighters recently rescued
a puppy that swam about
a mile across the Hudson River
from Manhattan to New Jersey.
They tried to return it,
but it had already found
an affordable home
with a backyard
and started a family.
[ Laughter ]
The appliance company Dyson
is set to launch
a set of noise canceling
headphones
with a detachable air purifier.
It's part of Dyson's
long-time mission
of trying to figure out what
the hell their company sells.
[ Laughter ]
"Headph-- Headphones?"
And finally, Google released
its annual year-end
search list yesterday,
and the most searched TV show
in the U.S. was "Euphoria,"
as in,
"Where can I get the drugs
they were doing
in last night's 'Euphoria'?"
And that was the monologue,
everybody!